Hey guys,
In this video, we're going to take a look
at what the Bible says about how men should dress.
And how they should take care of their appearance.
Now, I know some of you might be thinking,
Daniel, the Bible doesn't say anything about this.
Well, you're wrong.
The Bible has a lot
to say about how we present ourselves to the
world which will become clear in this video.
And this will shock many of you, because preachers
never talk about it or at least I haven't heard
a preacher talk about this in my whole life.
Now, you need to know that you can be a stumbling
block to an unbeliever, pushing them away from
the Gospel, just because of your appearance.
Yeah, let me explain.
There are too many Christian men that look sloppy.
Unprofessional.
Lazy.
And who don't care about their appearance at all.
You know, it is great that God is not like man.
Not like human beings.
Because He doesn't judge
based on our outside appearance.
What we look like.
You know, we always say this:
Don't judge a book by its cover.
But we do this.
We humans, because we are not perfect.
We are not God.
God - now He looks at your heart.
Your intentions.
Your character.
And that's how He judges you.
But we missed the part where
the Bible also says that men judge
according to the outside appearance.
Because they can't see right through you.
They're not God.
[1 Samuel 16:7]
Now most of the time, when people
read this, they just focus on the
part where it says that God judges the heart.
But they totally just leave out the part that
says that man focuses on the outside appearance.
And this is important for us to understand.
I'm going to explain to you why I'm
mentioning this a little bit later on.
But first I need to make this very clear.
Because I don't want you to misunderstand
the point I'm trying to make.
Vanity is a sin.
And it is a lot more important to focus
on the inside than on the outside.
Spiritual growth.
That's a lot more
important than just focusing on your outside
appearance, which will just return to dust anyway.
[Genesis 3:19]
So let me ask you, if you are God's
ambassador, living in His temple,
your body.
And people look at you when you represent God,
what do they see?
Their first impressions?
Someone who looks modest?
Who looks respectful?
Or someone who dresses in a way that
is flashy and attention-seeking.
Someone who professes to be a Christian
but is so self-absorbed that they don't
realize they're worshiping
themselves instead of God.
So I want to be very clear on this.
Dressing to impress for the wrong reasons.
Being vain.
Aiming to be the
guy who always wants the best and most costly
expensive brands, because of vanity, is wrong.
Or if you do it because you think
it improves your self-worth.
It is wrong, because your
self-worth is only found in God.
Vanity makes you self-absorbed,
arrogant, puffed-up, and selfish.
And can lead to envy, strife
and, well, an empty and sad life.
[Proverbs 16:18]
Now, what I'm talking about in this
video is all the way to the other side.
The other extreme.
Men.
Christian men.
Who think that they shouldn't take
care of their appearance at all.
So they don't groom.
They don't look modest.
They don't look respectful.
For example, if you want to
share the Gospel to someone.
You're walking towards them.
They see you.
They already start to make judgments
on you based on your appearance.
Man, this guy who looks sloppy.
It doesn't look respectful at all.
He doesn't look modest.
I don't want anything to do with him.
So they already decide there and then
that they don't want to listen to you.
So how are you going to share the Gospel to
them if they are already negative towards you?
Nowhere in scripture does it say that you
should not take care of your appearance.
It does say that your character is
more important and we all know that.
But it also says a great deal about how
you present yourself to other people.
I mean, you are God's ambassador.
Paul says...
[1 Corinthians 9:20-21]
Now listen to this.
[1 Corinthians 9:22]
You can't dress sloppy and go to talk to
someone who is very worldly and thinks about
the importance of appearance all the time.
Who's so self-absorbed that just wants to
wear designer brands all the time.
They probably wouldn't even want
to start listening to you.
And you can't dress in a nice
suit to talk to a homeless person.
You gotta think, yes, it is sad.
But this is the world that we live
in, all humans, not one is perfect.
And so people make assumptions based
on the appearance of other people.
People have sinful natures and those
sinful natures will judge you wrongly.
So dress according to the
occasion in order to save souls.
Don't always just dress like
a church person but dress more
in line with those who you are trying to save.
If you don't connect with people on their level,
then you'll be an obstacle
for them to hear the Gospel.
And you have to do it.
As you do everything now.
Because we're under the law of the
Spirit, which means everything you do
now should be through the Spirit, meaning
everything you do should be done for God.
Even normal things, like eating and drinking.
For example ...
[1 Corinthians 10:31]
Now some of you might say, ah come on
Daniel, something as basic as food and drink?
How do we do that for God?
First of all, it's not me who says it.
It's God's word that says this.
And when we look at something as
basic as food and drink, you need to
ask yourself, how much food do I eat?
Am I addicted to food?
A glutton?
Or am I so worried about my appearance
that I don't eat enough to live healthy?
And do I pray before I eat and thank
God for the food that he's given me?
So yes, even in the food and drink
that we consume we have to honor God.
And that goes for everything you do.
Everything must be done through the Spirit.
And that includes taking care of your appearance.
Some of you might still be asking, Daniel what
does this have to do with my appearance?
What is my faith?
What does that have to do with my appearance?
Everything!
Your appearance is a
reflection of your inner character.
A new creation that is different
from the person you used to be.
Now, you dress in a way that is modest,
respectful, and you are showing the
world that you are a man of faith.
So we should take care of our appearance.
We should groom ourselves properly
and keep ourselves clean.
Hygienic, healthy.
You should also dress more respectable so that
other people will feel more inclined to go and
talk to you, especially if you want to share
the Gospel to them. They want to feel, man, I
feel that I could just go and talk to this person.
This person feels warm, open, modest, respectable.
There's something about this person.
[1 Timothy 2:9-10]
Did you see that?
Your appearance
that goes together with your good works.
That is what you are showing to the world.
Now, I know Paul wrote this to women, right?
But does it not apply to men as well?
Today men can also dress in a
way that does not honor God.
And the Greek word here
used for modesty is kosmios.
And the same word is used when you talk to men.
[1 Timothy 3:2]
So your appearance is important.
Dressing modestly is for men and women.
The Bible even talks about bodily training.
[1Timothy 4:8]
Yes or no, training in godliness, growing
spiritually, you know really connecting to God.
God sees your heart.
That is a lot more important than
what's going on your outside appearance.
But you cannot live selfishly.
Oh, it's just me and my relationship with God.
What about other people?
You are called to share the Gospel.
So to do that, you cannot be
a stumbling block for other people.
You need to connect with them at their level.
And even though spiritual growth is important -
more important than bodily training - it doesn't
say here that bodily training is not important.
It says that it is of some value.
Now, some of you might be thinking, wow, did
they train their bodies in the time of the Bible?
Yes.
Don't think you're something special
because you live 2000 years later.
There's nothing new under the sun.
They also had athletes.
[1 Corinthians 9:25]
Now, how can you be the light of the world?
A sweet smelling aroma, live peaceably with
all people, if people don't even want to talk
to you because you don't use deodorant - you
smell - and you don't groom?
You look like someone who's
lazy, not respectable at all.
No, you need to be the light of the world.
They need to be able to think, man this
person, there's something about this person
I want ... to get to know this person.
Who are they, what are they thinking.
They look like someone who's modest, respectable.
Jesus says...
[Matthew 5:14]
Now of course, like I said, shining your
light goes hand in hand with your actions.
So your appearance and your actions, the
example that you set to non-believers,
all those things work together.
And of course, you cannot do it if you don't share
the gospel through the power of the Holy Spirit.
Because it is not us who are changing lives,
it is Jesus Christ.
And only He can do that through people
who are preaching through the Holy Spirit.
So don't do it through the flesh.
And next time, when you prepare yourself
in the morning, you're getting ready,
you're getting groomed, remember
to dress according to the occasion.
Work on your appearance in such a way that
is modest, respectful, and also appropriate.
Now, if you want more videos - more advice
for men - then please watch these videos here.
And I'll see you there.
And always remember - life is short,
so don't waste yours.
Bye guys.